and speaking of Biden or is he getting
all this money from According to a
recent filing a majority is from big
donors oh shocking Hollywood Moguls Tech
billionaires and liberal celebs and some
fashion icons too one of those Hollywood
Moguls Jeffrey katzenberg uh happens to
be Biden's campaign co-chair his 1.7
million dollars stood out not just for
the amount but because it brought his
questionable China ties back into Focus
now according to Jeffrey he visited
China every month for years while
running Dreamworks Animation and in 2012
he saw through a multi-billion dollar
deal with the Chinese government to
build a Production Studio in Shanghai
now here now is enniscanner freedom
human rights activist former NBA player
and it's it's certainly now he's not the
first guy to do business in China you
know we all know that Elon Musk has
major plants major business in China as
do so many other Fortune 500 CEOs but
who do you think China wants to win if
it's Trump versus Biden and why I mean
of course of course Biden I mean Jeffrey
is there I mean I saw about the news
about you know the Jeffrey and I believe
he is the Trojan Horse for China in the
Biden Administration so he is
essentially the by the extension into
China and uh this is the guy who said he
used to travel to uh China once a uh
every month for the last two and a half
years and I'm just so confused why our
current Administration right now so B
wants to be in bed with China so bad and
starting with our Administration not
only them but you look at Hollywood big
Tech academias NBA uh they're pretty
much all run by the Chinese government
so instead of dissing ourselves I'm just
my question is why are we uh want to get
into bed with the biggest dictatorship
in the world so bad well our our worst
enemy I mean even they say it's our it's
our biggest threat uh geopolitical
threat and it's the bite Administration
is as you noted so desperate to get back
into China's good graces watch this
we're not attempting to stifle economic
progress in China that we have and want
to continue to have a deep economic ties
after all this year our trade has
reached almost 700 billion dollars well
and it's what she leaves out is that we
have near record trade deficits with
China so our industrial base is eroding
China's is still humming in its past
even where it was for the pandemic so
you know she's trying to act like this
is oh parody and trade what a joke
exactly I mean the country that he still
talks about is the biggest dictatorship
in the world and everybody knows about
the human rights violation everybody
knows about the uyghurs and Tibetans I
mean when are we going to say enough is
enough you know everybody knows about
how they're pretty much brainwashing are
150 million Americans with Tick Tock
everybody everybody knows about the
Chinese balloon so it's money exactly
it's about money to say enough is enough
yeah well Biden's donors are Wall Street
and big Tech and all those I mean they
need their China business so the donors
are making these decisions for the buy
Administration Ned
um uh NS thank you very much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else